ce qui est fou c'est que c'est
finalement
c'est finalement vers eux qu'il faut se
tourner pour trouver des solutions parce
qu'ils sont confrontés de péquistes 21
heures je me disais ce site là il existe
depuis 2006 2007 depuis 15 ans c'est une
génération n'est ce pas loin quoi en
fait c'est ces îles sont ils sont là ils
sont en seconde là maintenant où ils
sont en premières enfin ils sont au
lycée ils ont grandi ils ont l'air bien
mais même en a même qui je vois parmi
les étudiants mais étudiante qui sont
donc des jeunes adultes qui ont grandi
avec avec sanogo dire le mal est déjà
fait en fait ils ont déjà lu accès à
tous à ce qu'on peut peut-être faire
c'est essayer de faire en sorte que que
les autres générations qui a remis ne
subissent pas les choses mais on ne m'a
déjà sept générations cobayes sept
générations cobayes elle existe là
maintenant elle rentre dans la sexualité
maintenant elle rend dans la sexualité
en ayant été biberonné aux bornes ou en
même temps elle rentre dans la sexualité
en étant conscientiser autour des
notions de consentement et c'est parce
qu'il rend dans la sexualité mais juste
après nous tous finalement ce sont aux
lycées maintenant ils étaient ils
étaient au collège au moment où au
moment de clubs 2010 est au collège ou à
la fin d'école ou importe donc ils
rentrent dans la sexualité maintenant
avec ces deux visions c'est à dire d'un
côté le lit par exposition images pornos
et d'un autre côté ils savent ce que
c'est que le consentement ils sont
comment dire très conscientisé autour
des notions de harcèlement des notions
anglo saxon de type slot shiming man ce
planning et c'est d'ailleurs intéressant
qu'on n'est pratiquement pas
d'équivalent dans la langue française
tout ce qui est arrivé aux sports non
porno divulgation ils sont beaucoup plus
au point que nous là dessus et ils ont
bien intégré il commence à bien intégrer
l'idée que la victime c'est bien la
personne qui est filmé à son insu c'est
et que la honte doit changer de camp et
que la honte c'est plutôt du côté des
harceleurs dans tout ça il ya quelque
chose qui est vachement qui a énormément
évolué sur les questions sexisme de
raciste d'écologie et de sa sont
beaucoup plus concentrés
ils sont tiraillés entre les deux
[Musique]